[Music]
right earlier today Hillary Clinton had
the audacity to accuse president Trump
of ignoring the cybersecurity threat
posed by Russia
okay the twice failed presidential
candidate warning quote the Russians are
still coming here with reaction Fox News
national security strategist Sebastian
Gorka nationally syndicated radio talk
show host Larry elder dr. korkor where
do I begin the dossier uranium one or
the reset look you have to laugh because
otherwise you get really really angry
there is no other Secretary of State
that this nation has ever had since 1776
that has done more damage to this
country from uranium one to FISA gate to
the fact that she had a server that was
illegal that had TSS CI s AP classified
information on it that US officials have
said is absolutely hackable by nation
states including Russia I really really
think that this woman needs to get off
social media get off Twitter and find a
lawyer who's better than the lawyers she
used to buy that Russian Russian
propaganda to get that illegal
surveillance warrant against caught a
page Larry well John as between Russian
meddling and the corrosive effect of our
left-wing media the left-wing media has
a lot more to answer to there was an
experiment done by a professor named Tim
Groseclose who wrote a book called left
turn he wanted to find out what kind of
effect the left-wing media had on how
people think how people reason and more
importantly how people vote for people
who never got the Washington Times the
conservative newspaper were offered free
subscription to the Washington Post a
liberal newspaper and vice versa those
that have the liberal newspaper were
offered free subscription to the
conservative newspaper and let's find
out how this affects how people vote and
in both cases people shifted the people
that got the liberal newspapers started
voting somewhat more liberally the
people that got the Washington Times the
conservative newspaper started voting a
lot more conservatively he concluded
that if people really got their news in
a fair and balanced way half liberal
half conservative the average state
would vote the way Texas does which is 8
to 10 points in favor of Republican that
is a corrosive effect of our left-wing
media far more damaging than any kind of
Russian meddling and remember in the
indictment of the third
Russians the conclusion was the meddling
had no effect on our electorate imagine
the effect of our electorate of our
left-wing media far more corrosive far
more powerful far more damaging that's
such a good point dr. korkor respond on
that because when you think of all that
they ignore it is so profound and how
they cover for their ideology and it's
so pervasive you just look at the last
13 months Sean what is this president
done with regards to Russia he's alleged
to be in the pocket of Vladimir Putin
but what has he done with the unleashing
of oil production in Anwar the XL
pipeline the fracking he's destroying
Russia stranglehold on gas and oil with
with NATO finally after 30 years saying
okay we're gonna pay for our own defense
and meet those 2% GDP targets he's
brought the Alliance back together and
by saying we're gonna arm the Ukrainians
he's doing the opposite of what Hillary
and Obama did who rolled over rolled
over when Russia invaded the meat grain
Larry the final work and don't forget
how they threw the Czech Republic in the
polls under the bus because the Russians
did not like the defense do that george
w bush had negotiated let's not forget
about all of those things that they've
done and Trump is considered to be too
cozy to Putin give me a break
yeah well certainly guys right on target
thank you both